العلاج الكتابي هو ممارسة لقاء
شخص لواحد مع شخص لمساعدته على
حل مشكلة من خلال قراءة
روايات رائعة ، والفكرة الكامنة وراء ذلك هي أن
الخيال العظيم يمكن أن يغير حياة
[الموسيقى]
أنا نورين توماسي وأنا نيويورك
أخبرني معالج Biblio المقيم في المدينة
قليلاً عن نفسك عندما كنت تبلغ من
العمر 33 عامًا في مدينة نيويورك ، فأنا أدخل
مرحلة حيث أفكر قليلاً في
مسيرتي المهنية حول طريقي إلى
الأبوة أو شيء طويل المدى
هناك  يمكن للكثير من التغييرات التي تم إجراؤها
على قراءة عمل خيالي أن
تغير منظورنا
وحياتنا لأننا ندخل مكان هذه
الشخصيات ، فهذا يساعدك على ممارسة هذه
المشاعر المختلفة بحيث إذا
كنت تجربها في الحياة الواقعية ، فأنت
بالفعل  نوع من هذا التدريب يمكن أن
يساعدك أيضًا على فهم نفسها ، فأنا
أختار 12 كتابًا لكل عميل ،
وآمل أن يقرأوا كتابًا واحدًا شهريًا
على مدار عام يتم
تنظيمهم ليأخذ القارئ في
رحلة أتمنى  هذه  يجلب لي الكثير من
البصيرة والتأمل